alors tariq ramadan vous êtes professeur
de philosophie au collège de genève et
d'islamologie à l'université de fribourg
auteur de nombreux ouvrages consacrés à
l'islam conférencier et vos
interventions sont largement diffusé
sous forme de cassette
ce qui fait qu'on emploie souvent à
votre sujet le terme de prédicateurs
alors c'est un personnage assez
charismatique orateurs star des jeunes
musulmans et et d'après le journal le
monde vos écrits vos cassettes aurait
influencé lilas et alma voilà donc c'est
pour ça que je dis ça parce que en fait
c'est j'écoute effectivement des
cassettes de monsieur par parmi d'autres
moi j'aime bien ces cas c'est ce que je
veux dire aussi c'est que je tiens à
insister sur le fait qu on a commencé à
apprendre apprendre l'islam
après avoir commencé à le pratiquer
parce que justement on voulait était
déjà a précisé à l'ats plusieurs
reprises corriger notre pratique parce
qu'effectivement on pratiquer sans
science de la tradition orale quoi voilà
voilà exactement
oui moi j'aimerais dire par rapport à la
façon dont vous m'avez présenter je
crois que c'est particulièrement
nécessaire il est particulièrement
nécessaire d'assister sur une chose
c'est à dire que systématiquement quand
des citoyens français de confession
musulmane peuvent entendre un discours
qui est un conte un discours qui leur
envoient leur esprit critique on dit
deux choses d'une part quand ce discours
il a un impact c'est une star et vous
savez ce que peut vouloir la connotation
du thermostat ce tout petit peu idole
quand je suis en fait non non non non et
non je peux comprendre que ce soit bien
cela étant dans le temps dans la
dimension religieuse star c'est un peu
guru guru c'est un peu quelqu'un qui
prive celui qui l'écoutent de l'esprit
critique qui l'aurait mais je crois que
c'est tout à fait fou et on le voit ce
soir je dire que moi ce qui me paraît
très important entendre aujourd'hui
c'est que les français de confession
musulmane jeunes femmes ou jeunes hommes
homme ou femme parce qu'il faut arrêter
de les appeler jeunes c'est un autre
temps qu'on utilise tout le temps c'est
à dire qu'un processus d'infantilisation
reste jeunes jusqu'à 40 ans parmi les
musulmans
alors que chez les autres et leurs
interlocuteurs se serait ce serait plus
précoce je crois qu'à partir d'un
certain moment on a une population
aujourd'hui qui est en train de revenir
à des références religieuses car un
esprit critique parmi ceux qui
reviennent à la pratique religieuse en
france la majorité sont des
étudiant c'est pas des laissés pour
compte c'est pas des paumés des
banlieues c'est des gens qui ont un
esprit critique qui se construisent
alors évidemment quand on n'a pas la
langue arabe et qu'on revient à l'islam
on passe par ce qu'on appelle du
bricolage mais quelle est la
construction de l'esprit critique par la
langue française il n'y a pas de
problème alors tariq ramadan en mai
dernier dans libération vous avez
déclarez pas de lois contre le foulard
moi j'avais d'abord écrire un article
avec un titre très clair qui était une
lettre ouverte à monsieur sarkozy à
monsieur ferry c'est le journal
libération qui a changé le titre qui a
ciblé sur la question du foulard parce
que ma thèse fondamentale c'est un peu
dans le sens de ce que vous avez dit
c'est qu'aujourd'hui cette question du
foulard
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt c'est à
dire que effectivement depuis dix ans le
nombre de cas n'ont pas augmenté et que
la laïcité dans sa règle ne s'opposait
pas à la pratique religieuse à partir du
moment où respecter trois règles saines
que vous avez rappelé pas de
prosélytisme pas de trouble à l'ordre
public et pas de dispense de courtiers
qui font assister à tous les coins
une fois que cela est dit le conseil
d'état dit une chose qui est très
importante et je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on en prenne acte au cas par cas vous
ne pouvez pas savoir quand une
conscience est contrainte si elle est
par un intégrisme potentiel ou si elle
est par un choix individuel stadium un
acte de confiance et ça se voit comment
ça se voit quand on discute avec les
gens non je ne peux pas savoir si vous
êtes vous même sous l'affluence d'un
gourou des médias j'en tire deux coups
oui par exemple et donc ma thèse elle
était de dire aux deux ministres
concernés le problème du foulard n'est
pas l'essentiel le problème c'est
véritablement un travail de fond dans la
politique sociale de ce pays parce
qu'effectivement si l'islam l'islam
n'est pas tout le problème
mais il ya un problème avec l'islam
effectivement mais il ya des problèmes
d'intégration de discrimination à
l'emploi de discrimination à
l'instruction c'est ça le vrai problème
pour vous c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt se foule alors alors c'est évident
que je redis alors vous savez je crois
qu'il ya une chose dont il faut qu'on se
rende compte en france la france est en
danger de la normalisation d'un certain
nombre de thèses d'extrême droite et en
particulier par rapport à la question de
l'islam elle appelle questions des
français d'origine immigrée
parce que on eu depuis jusqu'à qu'on va
parler de français d'origine immigrée
la seule différence entre en français de
souche dans ce pays et un français
d'origine immigrée
c'est que le français de souche c'est un
immigré de plus longue date c'est tout
c'est comme ça qu'il faut envisager la
question
il faut arrêter normalisée
dez d'exclusion et je crois quelque
chose qui est très importante qui a été
dit aujourd'hui ici sur ce plateau à
savoir on ne pourra pas faire l'économie
d'un dialogue au cas par cas et surtout
réinstaurer la confiance entre l'état
l'autorité publique et les citoyens de
confession musulmane dans ce pays
aujourd'hui un déficit de considérer un
problème c'est que l'islam contrairement
à d'autres religions englobe tout il
englobe la vie sociale aussi beaucoup
plus que que le que le catholicisme et
le judaïsme non alors ce que j'aimerais
dire par rapport à cela c'est que je
crois pas je crois qu'on a une idée on
dit oui ils font pas de différence entre
tous les dimensions de leur vie je crois
simplement une chose c'est
qu'effectivement une femme ou un homme
de confession musulmane pratiquante ou
pratiquants par la force des choses vous
allez voir ça à paraître dans son
quotidien
les cinq prières par jour le jeûne on va
venir dans le jeune c'est dans deux
semaines par la force des choses c'est
visible via une visibilité mais je crois
pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de différences
entre n'importe quelle est la plus
englobant que les autres religions
elle peut elle peut apparaître comme tel
mais finalement un catholique pratiquant
un juif pratiquant je veux dire il est
avec dieu le dimanche le samedi et avec
le diable la semaine il s'est simplement
d'être cohérent dans sa pratique c'est à
dire d'avoir une éthique de vie et c'est
ça la spiritualité réelles des gens
alors évidemment on n'est pas habitué à
cette éthique musulmane
on n'est pas habitués à la présence du
musulman parmi nous eh ben il va falloir
s'y habituer c'est que la france a
changé
je crois que tout le monde a compris
mais non mais je crois que l'on n'a pas
compris ce que le vous dire aussi que
c'était peut-être encore pire pour les
filles qui qui serait oppressés par
leurs familles qui seraient contraintes
à porter le voile parce qu'elles sont
les retire de l'école il le rappeler
qu'est ce qui les attend on la remet
chez les intégristes sapho faut être
cohérent mais au moins on la laisse à
l'école ça va lui permettre d'acquérir
des diplômes une situation
éventuellement une émancipation et s'est
fait faire frire oui moi j'aimerais
c'est logique
oui je crois que là aussi parce qu'on a
entendues par exemple de sos racisme un
temps au 10ème maintenons une loi au il
faut pas les accepter à l'école puis
qu'ils fassent des des écoles islamiques
jeudi c'est le pire qu'on puisse
imaginer véritablement une école
islamique ce peut être le ghetto faut
arrêter avec ça aujourd'hui
l'islam n'est pas en cause dans la
violence des banlieues
l'islam n'est pas en cause dans le
traitement qu'il y à des jeunes filles
aujourd'hui est des viols collectifs
c'est souvent d'ailleurs des jeunes qui
ne se connaissent pas leur religion qui
sont en mal sur le plan de l'intégration
sociale en discrimination à l'emploi en
discrimination même dans l'instruction
il faut également qu'on dise de ce point
de vue là qu'il ya un vrai problème il
faut pas qu'on y les problèmes je crois
qu'il ya aussi de la part des citoyens
de confession musulmane un certain
nombre de questions auxquelles il faut
qu'il réponde
là on n'est pas en train de jouer il
faut surtout pas qu'on commence une
d'entrer dans une ère de victimisation
l'amant je suis aussi très ferme avec le
public musulman
il ya des vraies questions à poser sur
la discrimination vis-à-vis des femmes
il ya des vrais problèmes à poser sur le
fait que des jeunes culture de lac de
cultura peuvent entretenir un machisme
en utilisant l'islam contre les jeunes
ça c'est inacceptable
il faut qu'on le dise et en plus hier
qu'est ce qu'on disait de ces jeunes
filles on disait c'est le père ou le
frère et vous savez ce qu'on leur dit
aujourd'hui leur dit elle son auto
aliéné c'est encore pire
c'est à dire que maintenant c'est par
leur propre choix qu'elle sadien le
processus de libération des femmes
je dire jamais en sortir mais ce sera le
mot de la fin on n'ira pas beaucoup plus
loin ce soir je vous remercie beaucoup
mesdemoiselles vous êtes est très jolie
merci mille autres femmes alors de
rester avec moi au revoir on va
donc tariq ramadan vous êtes très
critiquée par certains on vous accuse
parfois de double discours
on dit que vous êtes un fondamentaliste
moderne comme ça et que finalement vous
avez une vieille rhétorique mais qu'elle
est bien emballé et bien présenté faut
dire que votre grand père était
fondateur des frères musulmans en egypte
et votre frère hani ramadan a été
suspendu d'enseignement après avoir
justifié la lapidation des femmes
adultères et assimilés le sida un
châtiment divin alors quelle est votre
position par rapport à votre grand père
et par rapport à votre frère d alors bon
je vous remercie d'abord de commencer
par cela parce que ça me permet de
répéter ce que je dis mais cette fois ci
encore de façon plus explicite
j'ai par rapport à mon grand-père
l'attitude de n'importe quel esprit
critique vis-à-vis d'une histoire c'est
à dire que je le remets dans son
contexte des années 30 et des années 40
il y a des choses pour lesquelles j'ai
un énorme respect 2000 écoles créer un
travail fait pour les pauvres de
l'alphabétisation la résistance à la
colonisation et je crois qu un esprit
qui s'est levé contre la colonisation
est à ce prix un esprit de dignité puis
à des réponses qu'il a données pour sont
en 1940 sur le registre éthique sur le
registre religieux qui doivent être
mises et et contextualisés quant à mon
frère j'ai effectivement mis souvent en
évidence le fait que sur un certain
nombre de thèses fondamental nous
n'étions pas d'accord et j'ai pris
j'ai une attitude critique et sélective
et une attitude de distanciation donc
encore une fois ce que j'ai toujours dit
à mes détracteurs depuis 20 ans que je
parle et avec une vingtaine de bouquin
publié
je vous demande une seule chose sinon
vous n'êtes pas crédible montrez-moi
clairement où ce double langage se situe
à quel moment j'ai pu la voir parce que
je dis à plus forte raison à tous ceux
qui m'écoutent de ces français et
européens de confession musulmane que la
chose contre laquelle il faut absolument
que nous luttions aujourd'hui nous en
tant que musulman c'est ce double
langage justement c'est un langage à la
mosquée entre nous et un langage sur la
place publique avec nos interlocuteurs
alors vous êtes récemment sorti de
l'ambigüité qu'on vous reproche parfois
tariq ramadan on peut considérer que
vous avez franchi la ligne jaune
il s'agit d'un texte écrit par vous
refusez par rebond la page ouverte de
libération où ils vous exprimer l'air
assez régulièrement mais là ça a été
refusé par libération par le monde et ce
texte a été diffusé sur le site internet
des alter mondialistes avec qui vous
préparer le forum social européen
alors vous cité dans ce texte un certain
nombre d'intellectuels bernard henri
lévy alain finkielkraut andré glucksmann
alexandre adler bernard kouchner pierre
andré taguieff tout ce juif ou supposé
tel puisque taguieff n'est pas juif et
vous dit en gros pour résumer votre
propos qu'ils sont juifs avant d'être
intellectuelle et que leurs positions
politiques répondent à des logiques
communautaires ou des logiques disons
nationaliste c'est à dire la défense de
l'état d'israël voilà alors c'est grave
ou vous le savez c'est très très grave
parce que des listes de juifs en a connu
100 francs 142 on a connu ça avec le pen
qui avait cité un certain nombre de deux
journalistes juifs en les amalgamant et
vous êtes disent on ne s'était pas
arrivé depuis le pen quoi donc d'un seul
coup on se dit est-ce qu'il a pété les
plombs
alors pour en parler avec nous on va
appeler le journaliste qui a repéré sa
sur le site altermondialiste et qui en a
parlé dans le nouvel observateur
j'accueille claude askolovitch
[Musique]
tougas colovic bonsoir auteur de
nombreux ouvrages dont un sur jospin qui
nous a valu le plaisir de faire votre
connaissance ici journalistes comme je
l'aï dit au nouvel observateur donc
quand d'après tariq ramadan quand
kouchner glucksmann bruckner soutiennent
la guerre d'irak c'est parce que c'est
une guerre sioniste voilà ce que dit
tariq ramadan j'ai pas dis ça je dis
passagers sierra non non non non là je
suis très précis dans le texte je ne dis
pas que c'est une guerre sioniste est
d'ailleurs j'aimerais être très clair
sur la façon dont vous présentez les
choses
il a été dit d'ailleurs par monsieur
askolovitch que j'avais pensé que
taguiyev était juive dans mon en mai
citation ce que je savais ne pas être le
cas avant même d'avoir écrit le texte
j'avais même mis tribalat dont je sais
également qu'il n'est pas juive
donc moi je ne mettais pas pris
uniquement à des intellectuels juifs en
pensant que tous les thèmes ou en les
stigmatisant je dis simplement très
précisément une chose aujourd'hui sur la
scène médiatique française
il apparaît que sur des analyses sur le
plan national
on nous propose aujourd'hui une lecture
des réalités en france qui sont
totalement biaisé et exagéré et
passionné quand on dit par exemple avec
les actes antisémites que nous assistons
à des nuits de cristal en france je dis
aujourd'hui que cela va trop loin et
qu'on ne peut pas faire semblant de ne
pas entendre
derrière le discours de finkielkraut est
derrière ce les sous-entendus de ce que
dit taguiyev un soutien à l'état
d'israël et surtout l'idée
qu'aujourd'hui en france les musulmans
sont un train de sortir les français de
confession musulmane sont un train de
sortir du communautarisme
ils sont en train de venir dans la
société civile et il s'exprime contre
l'oppression des palestiniens et il
s'exprime contre les discriminations et
ça on n'a pas vraiment on ait envie de
les repousser vers le communautarisme
c'est la première des choses sur la
scène internationale j'ai jamais parlé
de bruckner par ailleurs c'est bernard
henri lévy qu'il le dit mais moi je n'ai
jamais cité
je dis simplement une chose je dis
qu'effectivement tout à coup sur la
scène internationale on a des gens qui
interviennent comme adler qui
soutiennent adler ou ou kouchner qui
soutiennent l'intervention en irak mais
qu'ils ne nous disent jamais dans les
faits qu effectivement l'intervention
américaine en irak en ayant des intérêts
américains c'est évident l'amérique
défoncé intérêts défend d'autres
intérêts de géostratégie de protection
de l'état d'israël
monsieur est ce que le vih bien c'est
tellement classique tout-terrain
j'entendais tariq ramadan parler de la
pénétration des idées de le pen
alors je vous dis refus journalisme je
peux exégètes je suis pas religieux
bêtement france est laïque et
républicain et journalistes j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur le front national
ni un livre là-dessus je travaille
également sur les alter mondialistes et
comme ça tu tombais sur le texte de
monsieur ramadan
mais quand je lui ai juste dit pas ça y
est bingo c'est les mêmes c'est la même
chose même vision complotiste de
l'histoire
même manière d'agréger des gens en
fonction de leurs origines réelles ou
supposées
parce que sur taguiyev et même manière
de nous entraîner dans des débats odieux
taguiyev et juifs pas juive tribalat et
juifs agile mais comment parle-t-on
non mais où on est en france on est dans
les années 30 permettait ramadan on est
dans les années 30
en 1936 et un député d'extrême droite
qui s'appelait xavier vallat qui a été
commissaire général aux questions juives
de vichy par la suite qui s'adressait
ainsi à léon blum leader socialiste
devenant président du conseil qui lui
disait pour la première fois ce vieux
pays gallo-romain la france un autre mon
pays va être gouvernée par un juif via
ce type
l'identification désigner des gens non
plus pour ce qu'il pense pas ce qu'ils
disent qu'ils ont peur de penser de dire
ce qu'ils disent lévy kouchner luxe
manet les autres j'en sais rien je ne
m'aime pas là dedans mais ramener leurs
prises de position ramier de réflexion
ramener leurs livres à la seule unique
et obsessionnelle question de leur
origine c'est tragique mais je sais que
ça en fait ça glucksmann jamais
glucksmann n'a pris des prises de
position je suis peut-être pas toujours
d'accord avec ce qu'il raconte notamment
sur la guerre en irak mais jamais
glucksmann n'a avancé ses positions en
raison de ses origines en raison de la
défense de l'état d'israël bernard
kouchner
bernard kouchner il est médecin était à
lyon des étudiants communistes et de la
gauche peut dire qu'ils les marathoniens
on peut dire qu'il est socialiste on
peut dire qu'il est moins bien on peut
dire qu'ils les droits de l'hommiste et
vous dire qu'il est plein de trucs
kouchner c'est la première fois depuis
40 ans que bernard kouchner intervient
dans le débat français piles et
étudiants que kouchner est désigné comme
juif alors kouchner a peut-être peur
d'être pro américain ils avaient tort
d'être pour la guerre en irak - mon
journal nouvel observateur qui par
parenthèse monsieur ramadan c'est
pratiquement fondé sur la défense du
droit des palestiniens
alors me fait pas le coup de sharon ici
c'est pas la peine mais kouchner
jamais depuis qu'il intervient n'avait
été définie comme juif et c'est ce mode
de pensée que l'arctique de tariq
ramadan est venu réintroduire dans les
bacs français jusqu'à présent il n'y
avait que l'extrême droite qui le
faisait il ya donc ce que je disais un
autre extrême droite souriante gentil
poli policé mais qu'ils pensent de la
même manière beaucoup de gens croient en
tariq ramadan ce qu'il aura fait en
publiant ce texte avec ses soubassements
fascisant c'est pas un cadeau c'est pas
un cadeau qui nous a fait
vous vous rendez vous ce que vous vendez
j'aimerais vous dire une chose la chine
c'est très grave si on va dire une chose
acquise en cuir depuis que cet article
est sorti on ne m'a jamais jamais
répondu sur le fond qu'on vienne me dire
vous êtes antisémites le 24 décembre
j'en ai pris mes du monde entier
musulmans parce que j'ai écrit un
article une tribune du monde en disant
existe-t-il un antisémitisme islamique
est gelée dénoncer je l'écris dans les
livres j'ai écrit un livre avec alain
gresh qui soit dit en passant n'est pas
seulement à t'aimer 10 ans du mac est
aussi de tradition juive
j'ai demandé à la martinière au moment
où il y avait les actions d origine
mesurera maintenant qu'est le débat
républicain
non mais quelle belle manière graphique
de leur vie noté risque de s'abriter des
leurs origines des partenaires alors
j'aime sur un matelas vêtements cela le
communautarisme est ce que je suis on
m'a même aux fascistes répondu autant
que vous voulez et je répondrai sur mon
article sont manière de travailler
poursuit tout simplement une chose ça ne
vous gêne jamais à vous de dire je suis
un intellectuel musulman
j'ai pas le droit de dire d'un
intellectuel qu'il est juste pourquoi ça
ne vous gêne pas dire je suis un
intellectuel musulman et que j'étais
gêné c'est un intellectuel musulman je
crois mais redire des intellectuels
gilles dont il ya des intellectuels
musulmans mais pas des attaques et je ne
veux rien dire
monsieur vous avez pas dit qu'ils
étaient juifs
voilà ils le reconnaissent d'ailleurs
angers un souffle kouchner dont je pense
c'était la première fois que je sais que
vous leur dites pas qu'ils sont juifs
ils le disent je dis l'oublier parce
qu'ils sont juifs qu'ils écrivent ça
n'en oublient qu'ils sont juifs avant de
les chasser les tuer si je suis très
précis dans le texte que je dis c'est
que dans ce qu'ils disent ou dans ce
qu'ils ne disent pas on voit qu'il y a
soit une relation à une communauté de
foi ou d'ethnie qu'ils ont le droit mais
qu'ils nous le disent
soit une relation israël j'aimerais que
vous me disiez de façon claire ou
glucksmann ou kouchner ou adler ou
finkielkraut prenne une position ferme
de principe par rapport à israël qui ne
soit pas sélective je l'attends
finkielkraut il fait partie de paix
maintenant non mes pénates entendez vous
savez ce qu'il a dit dans le décryptage
ce documentaire ce soi-disant
documentaire il dit mais les israéliens
n'avaient pas le choix de voter sharon
on n'a pas le choix de voter pour un
homme d'extrême droite qui est un est
une terreur on t'a bernard henri lévy
l'a pas soutenu la guerre d'irak tenant
alors sur ce plan là il a eu un moment
où ils avaient une hésitation puis
ensuite des plantes
il n'a pas fait d'accord alors sur ce
plan-là de toutefois sa noyade mais non
mais simplement une chose c'est que à
partir d'un certain moment je veux dire
il faut nous dire il faut qu'on ait un
débat de fond parce que ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est que la lecture
des faits sur la scène internationale
est en train de nous ramener sur le
champ national et moi ce que je suis en
train de demander
contrairement à ce qui m'a été reproché
tariq ramadan communautariste j'aimerais
vous dire une chose depuis 20 ans que je
travaille dans la communauté musulmane
la communauté de foi musulmane depuis 20
ans que j'y travaille
je n'ai cessé d'appeler les citoyens de
confession musulmane à sortir du ghetto
et ça on me le reproche
une dernière chose parce que moi mon
sujet c'est la politique au départ
j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi tariq
ramadan avait pété un plomb là
maintenant et est sortie tellement
prudent des beaux articles
auparavant un mois je compte une réponse
est très simple
tariq ramadan rêve d'être un mentor
tariq ramadan est important il refait le
monde connaît don helder camara plein de
gens tariq ramadan à des conférences le
premier secteur etc ramadan dans le
paysage de l'islam français le
professeur suisse tariq ramadan n'existe
pas l'islam français s'organisent et
c'est une belle chose
nicolas sarkozy capte un défaut par
ailleurs entre plus d'organismes
français quand nicolas sarkozy va
discuter avec l'islam français ne parle
pas avec monsieur ramadan alors que fait
monsieur ramadan mon dieu ce que font
tous les démagogues un petit coup sur la
pompe antijuive ce que faisait le pen
pour exister
ça ne mange pas de pain mais je vais en
tuer les intellectuels de risque
j'espère j'espère parce que j'ai une
toute autre estime une toute autre
opinion et tout autre amour de mes
concitoyens de toutes origines
claude vous dites là ce que le vide ce
que c'est un dérapage contrôlé comme le
pen quand il fait ses blagues pourra
délibérer absolument pour exister et
pour porter un débat pourrait pointer le
doigt en disant dit que les juifs ont
répondu je suis un peu surpris parce que
quand on est on est malveillant dit cet
homme là il a un impact incroyable sur
les jeunes
c'est d'ailleurs il est derrière toutes
les afin et puis quand on veut être
malveillant tout à coup je suis tout
seul je suis en recherche
je veux dire je suis obsessionnellement
antisémite est personnellement touché
dans ma personnalité
parce que je ne suis pas reconnu jeudi
avoir été ce délire clair à partir d'un
certain moment soit un discours à une
discussion qui est un tout petit peu
articulée c'est-à-dire raisonnable et
puis on regarde les arguments tels
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui je dis
simplement une chose de tout ce que j'ai
entendu on ne m'a pas apporté des
arguments qu'ils soient des arguments
qui soient fondées mais surtout est que
les gens pensent excusez-moi tariq
ramadan et peut-être que les gens
pensent qu' on n'a pas apporté
d'arguments à ça aussi c'est génial dans
le plâtre ou d'acheter parce qu'on
assène me lever quand le pen dit ici des
journalistes juifs
évidemment je ne citerai pas ici
personne lui réponds parce que ça se
fait plus depuis quarante-deux peut-être
que c'est pour ça que j'en vois je
écoutez moi ce que je suis en train de
mettre en évidence et on peut maintenant
dire oui il a pointé des intellectuels
juifs
j'en ai pointer certains c'est
pratiquement la majorité et d'autres je
dis simplement une chose de vraiment est
ce qu'on est prêt en france aujourd'hui
avoir un véritable débat parce que ça va
mal parce que là la question
israélo-palestinienne il vient jusque
sur le territoire français alors de deux
choses l'une soit on dit cette présence
discours qui s'abstient de condamner
israël et qui nous présente une région
du monde sur l'islam je dis que c'est ça
le vrai problème et on veut pas me
répondre on est en train de me dire
antisémites alors j'ai prouvé textes à
l'appui engagement à l'appui en disant
vous savez j'étais dans des salles à
l'environnement ce que vous dites vous
c'est pour comprendre ici
comme il faut la façon dont on nous
restitue le problème israélo-palestinien
il faut savoir que les gens que vous
citez sont juifs et qui sent son nom ne
vous dira non je dis pas ça je te même
site à kiev n'est pas juif mais aussi
tribalat n'est pas joué il mériterait
lemaitre teddy a fait contre
l'antisémitisme et je dis simplement une
chose c'est que la lecture mais ils
fondèrent qui n'intervient pas sur
israël et la palestine a peut-être tort
mais oui mais bienvenu manière berlin
des couches monsieur bazin défendeurs 10
3 ans je vous en prie ne faites pas le
coude humaniste pas ça pas vous parce
qu'ils pas ma maison quand à bercy c'est
le grand dessein un émail maintenant
c'est un humaniste
aujourd'hui dans le monde un humaniste
dans le monde ne peut pas on y arrive un
humaniste dans le monde ne peut pas
aujourd'hui se taire sur la politique
israélienne je ne comprends pas qu'un
humaniste soit sélectif au point de
faire signer deux jours monotones la
politique étrangère sur un bateau s'est
couché en interview c'est parce que
normalement ils devraient intervenir
il devrait intervenir alors mais le
dernier point j'ai mon nom il ya tout
dernier point juste une chose c'est moi
non mais véritablement aujourd'hui ma
thèse par rapport à ça c'est pas qu'ils
sont juifs ou pas juif je dis
qu'aujourd'hui il y a cédé protease
raéliens j'ai jamais parlé de complot de
lobby je suis absolument pas je fais la
différence entre les etats-unis et la
france je dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des pro israélien et il y a des
gens qui sont des sionistes notoire qui
met une chape de plomb sur les vraies
questions et qui est que je dise que
nous avons en attendant la même droit
que je peux terminer elle est toujours à
quai les mutations de vocabulaire
limitation au no more fait un raid au
moment où les français sont un train de
les français de confession musulmane
sont en train de sortir des ghettos et
qu'il s'exprime aujourd'hui avec
d'autres partenaires avec d'autres
religions la crainte aujourd'hui vient
de personnes qui sont en train de dire
attention l'antisémitisme revient par
les jeunes arabes par les immigrés et ça
ça n'est pas acceptable
il faut dénoncer l'antisémitisme mais il
faut lutter contre ses causes mm sur les
lectures internationale n'auront qu'à
question et je pense que pour les gens
vous êtes deux intellectuels vous faites
vous êtes des exemples j'ai trouvé le
débat trop agressif pour qu'on puisse
comprendre beaucoup de choses et c'était
dommage
est ce qu'au niveau de la symbolique
vous seriez prêt est ce que vous seriez
capable de vous serrer la main
simplement parce que vous avez là prêts
à monter l'un contre l'autre et se
trouve ça pourrait délivrer une image
qui serait très positive et ça m est des
bonnes vibrations
je veux dire par là c'est est ce que
vous êtes capables
hors caméra de parler concrètement de
sabou l'accusé dont il se défend
on peut aussi écouter les gens attendent
et vous dire je peut serrer la main
ramadan je tends la main plein de gens
même à l'open plein de gens quand je
travaille je t'ai renommage dit bonjour
aux gens serre la main
c'est vrai j'en les océans la main à la
maison mais jamais je n'y vois aucune
espèce de symbolique oui bonjour je te
serre la main
mais même si à la main j avais pas la
main maintenant mais je peux m'en passer
le plateau ça dépend des fois depuis 20
ans que je suis sur le terrain de ces
discussions là on me battant contre
l'antisémitisme
mais on me battant également contre le
temps ces pointes et 10 juin je me
serrer la main
je les fais j'écris j'ai écrit un livre
des articles pour me battre avec ça moi
je ne serrerait pas la main comme un
acte symbolique mais comme la nécessité
de ce dialogue et qui comprendra que ce
que je dis c'est pour notre bien commun
tous et pour l'avenir commun de la
citoyenneté française et humaines ça
soit le moment où on est sûr de ne rien
rater de l'ina l'institut
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus